[Music]
homie look what I become
okay Eric uh so if we are live that
we're gonna do it we had a false start
so we're doing it again the other one
that we went live was a podcast from
yesterday but we're live okay special
podcast 234 we're going to talk about
the State of the Union speech we have
Vincent oshana in the house we have the
great Roger Stone in the house Kai we
got a lot of things to talk about it was
an interesting speech if you did get a
chance to watch it there was a legendary
history making kiss that I think it will
be talked about for many many decades to
come uh that deserves to be on the cover
of Time Magazine it's one of those top
events uh of the Year somebody needs to
write a book and put that on the cover
of it absolutely uh we're going to talk
about how the first uh Prime Minister
President Who uh somebody will talk
about who used Chad gbt to prepare a
speech we'll react to that Elon had some
thoughts and concerns about Chad gbt
that's going on a few other statistics
on what's going on with the economy
we'll touch on that as well and then as
well as a uh yesterday we went live with
a uh what do you call it Roland Martin
podcast we had uh that did very well we
got a lot of commentary on it you know
it's been a lot of reactions a lot of
other channels reacted to it it was
great really enjoyed the banter in the
debates I think the audience won uh
there's a video that Jason Whitlock I
think it's last 20 videos reacting to an
event that took place which we will uh
which I will uh react to at the end of
the podcast and give you my thoughts but
having said that let's get right into it
Roger you've seen many city of the Union
speeches okay you've been around you've
seen a couple of these things how would
you rate yesterday's was it a good for
them and if it was in what way I think
it was a very effective speech like any
president you stress the things you
think are going well or the things you
can put the best possible spin on uh you
you try to ignore or de-emphasize those
things that are not going well there
were times during the speech where I
could close my eyes and I could almost
see Donald Trump rhetorically America
First bring back America American
manufacturing jobs uh stand up to China
taking Credit in some cases for things
that Trump did no it was Trump who
capped the price of insulin for example
and while it is true that an increase of
12.8 million jobs is very impressive it
doesn't take into consideration how many
jobs were lost because of the covid-19
pandemic and therefore it's still true
that there are fewer people working
today than we're working at the end of
the Trump Administration and then of
course the president continues to
maintain I inherited a mess on inflation
no actually he inherited the lowest
inflation rates in decades and it's his
number one problem Republic Republicans
particularly understand the correlation
between spending and inflation I'm not
sure all voters understand the
correlation between spending and
inflation but that's uh that's where the
presidential campaign's about and he
acts like a man who's running
so do you think like if you watch the
the State of the Union do you think
um it gave a better optic for the
audience to say you know what I think
this guy can run again and go run for
the next time for himself do you think
it was a good look for Democrats do you
think Democratic voters are sitting
there saying well in your face
Republicans I thought he did a good job
how would you see specifically with
Optics because I know a lot of politics
there's policies but then there's also
Optics how did he look in regards to
Optics uh a little too soon to say okay
because you have the event then you have
the interpretation of the event by the
media then you have the impact of that
on voters the number of people who think
he should run has been systematically
dropping it was
52 several months ago it's now down to
about 37. we'll see if it bounces or
floats back up remain remains to be seen
I thought that his the content overall
was better than his performance I I
never think it's a good idea to yell I
think I think yelling I mean that never
happens we don't we don't like that
either well it's too hot I mean it's too
hot for a political leader you you in
fact when you want them to listen you
actually drop your voice on the more
important points something Nixon was
commented on so I I he goes back and
forth between uh between being
conciliatory but yelling uh overall
though there has to be some consistency
this is this is a president who only
months ago had a very dark speech in
which he basically uh condemned 50 of
the people calling them extremists
because they don't agree with him so on
the one hand he wants to be conciliatory
with Republicans and I was glad that he
talked about cancer and some of these
other issues where hopefully we can get
some bipartisan cooperation but to talk
about the fentanyl crisis and not
attribute it to the open borders uh
policies of this Administration it's
just unrealistic the problem in our
border is not lack of money or lack of
resource sources its lack of will it's a
it's a it's a bad policy illegal
Crossings were down to a trickle at the
end of the Trump Administration illegal
Crossings now are hitting records I
think this is largely responsible for
the fentanyl crisis in the country so
you can't you can't fight fentanyl
unless you're prepared to close down the
borders so can we can we do this can we
uh show the clip uh uh uh Rob if you can
of a few different things because I got
notes Here I got the good bad ugly uh
score what was a win to me for democrats
for uh uh him what was awkward what was
a loss different topics but can you show
the clip of the kiss that Jill Biden and
Kamala Harris if you can find that while
you're doing that go ahead do you know
who so did you see it Roger when uh Joe
Biden came down and I didn't realize
this her husband his name is Doug emoff
he's the first second gentleman of our
entire political he's commonly his
husband and Jill Biden came there and it
wasn't just like listen we're Middle
Eastern yeah so Roger when we when we
see other family members you know maybe
a kiss some some people do three they
literally locked eyes and it wasn't just
okay accidental here it was a it was a
moment where even the people around them
were like are we are we on camera right
now and it's like if coma like if that
was somebody like my mom if that was her
over there then that happened my mom
would have jumped over I don't give a
damn jumped over these aisles and beat
the hell out of jail like that's that's
just it's just it's ridiculous like look
he knows he's about to get there he
knows what's coming he's about to give
it to us he's the one that initiated he
starts okay can we see like who's the
old lady in the middle that just stuck
right there you guys know who that is
who is that don't recognize that's
probably that's probably like his mom or
something yeah can we play that Rob I
want to see that or no sound oh
that was a good one
look at that I love him more than three
that's on the lips right I mean that's
straight up on the list of course look
so so here's my first one here's my
question here's my question I think you
were born you can run for office right
you're essentially born in America so
everybody here is a natural citizen I'm
not so to me is this an American thing
like is it normal for one who to kiss
another
man's wife let alone is that an American
is that a normal thing to do no uh it's
this and this is just a distraction I
mean this is like a UK Daily Mail moment
you know uh but no I don't think it I
don't think it's a cultural thing by the
way you can run for anything but
president United States Pat could who
yes you yeah I'm not interested I
understand but just the fact that you're
uh not not Natural Born whatever that
means doesn't mean you couldn't run for
it yeah so I mean to me when I see
something like this I'm a little bit
weirded out by it you know to to say hey
it's okay to do something like this do
you find that weird as well is it just
me I found it very weird I was listening
to this in the car this morning and I
didn't even notice it until we we played
it back and I was like what that is very
weird and the internet has definitely
been been sharing this more than enough
and you guys know you guys know who that
is that's Paul Pelosi with the hat right
there and that's Bono on the left thank
God he didn't sing
yeah that's hilarious that would have
been hilarious yeah what would he well
it's just it's just an awkward thing to
do especially when you know all the
cameras are on you they're so they're
applauding you you just walked into the
room and then that's the first like
that's she didn't do this with anybody
else it was just it was just to the
second gentleman so so does anybody care
is this like even anything so meaning
let's just say uh uh let's just say
Trump's wife kisses uh Mike Pence Mike
Pence it's kind of like doing that right
or is that like who would that be no it
would be Mike Pence's well that doesn't
work because it would be opposite it's
just still somebody's I don't know man
somebody's wife or husband like locking
lips or that I I that was that right off
the rip because that was the first thing
I saw I was like oh my God that really
just happen and then that's like the
open would calling uh Chuck Schumer the
uh minority what do you call him right
when he went on the stage he had a gap
right off the right off the rim okay so
anyways to me it's very weird but I I
have my own thoughts on this I'll get
into it in Akai Vinnie the rest of you
guys I'd love to get a little bit more
content on this as well so first of all
I think uh the following about what
happened if we were to survey a hundred
different people say 40 Republicans 40
Democrats 20 independent Libertarians
and say
how well of a job you think Biden is
going to do given the State of the Union
speech okay and they put their scores
before before not after before I think
the average person is going to say you
know four a five and what it's what
they're going to expect for him to do
right it's like a guy you have that's on
the bench who averages six points a game
and you put him in he scored 17 points
you're like dude we were not expecting
17 points from this guy I think that's
what he did he went in and I think it
was a very good look for him the
Democrats again my opinion on what
happened the most awkward part was that
okay I think the part that I give credit
to is the following I'll get into that
here in a minute here's some of the
things he talked about number one
inflation he blamed Putin on inflation
we caught that so that Blame Game you
don't gain credibility there anytime you
do that but we know where that's going
and then the last two years 10 million
jobs 10 million Americans have applied
to start a new business okay so you're
kind of appealing to the small business
owner we get that that's a good speech
that's given then the next thing was
social security every five years you
know how Rick Scott is negotiating for
this I think that was a massive massive
victory for him it because it was off
the cuff it was uncomfortable if you can
play it this is like if you show a
highlight of Michael Jordan going over
Sam Perkins and switching and making the
the shot with his left hand I think this
was his moment if you want to just press
play so the audience can zoom just zoom
in so they can hear it and see it yeah
zoom in even closer
even closer you don't need to see the
words just to face there you go if you
can click on it so watch this just a
moment audio on the bottom right
there wasn't all the oil refineries
anyway so this isn't the one this is
this is a completely different thing
this is the oil refinery one the one I'm
talking about is where uh what is this
one here no that's a different one as
well there's a clip where the
Republicans and him they're talking
about social security oh yeah and
they're talking about Medicare so if you
go on YouTube or Twitter and type on
Social Security Medicare Biden it'll
come up I think that was his highlight
and you know I know it's very hard for
Republicans to even give credit to them
I think that's his highlight is that the
one how many minutes is that buck 37
that should be the one press play and
audio
watch this here's when it gets nasty I
get it unless I agree to the economic
plans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are watch this
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share so I'm very happy
some Republicans want Medicare and
Social Security Sunset
I'm not saying it's a majority yeah what
one person talked to you about it great
setup yeah anybody who doubts it look
contact my office
wait wait watch for it wait for it
proposal
that means Congress doesn't vote
thank you
no I tell you I enjoy conversion
you know
Congress doesn't keep the programs the
way they are they that's what other
Republicans say I'm not saying it's a
majority of you I don't even think it's
even a significant
but it's being proposed by individuals
I'm not politely not naming them but
it's being proposed by some of you
look folks
the ideas
that we're not going to be we're not
going to be moved into being threatened
to default on the debt if we don't reach
that
folks
watch he Corners them
and then he makes all the Republicans
stand up watch this
is his highlights
so folks
as we all apparently agree
Social Security Medicare is off the off
the books now
all right watch this and then no hang on
you don't have any more oh the best part
is missing you know what's the best part
what he does right after this he says so
can we all stand up if you agree to
protect seniors and he makes every body
stand body stand up that even booed him
so look if you if you can go minute 40
to go all the way to the last 10 seconds
yeah that's the one
don't do that don't do that because it's
hurting the ears
all right
we got unanimity
go back to Buck 20. yeah go back
so folks as we all apparently agree
stand up you can just pause it
gets everybody else to stand up so I
thought that was a defining moment for
him that's a highlight okay for him to
and this is why let me explain why okay
you have to know this is we don't sit
here every week and talk about how
amazing Joe Biden is okay but to me
strategically when you
go off the script and it's all about the
teleprompter and there is a 75 second
moment that you can't lean on the
teleprompter and that comes off the cuff
to do that I think you got to give the
guy credit on being able to leverage on
any kind of corn in McCartney because he
took away a couple cards away to
negotiate now I would love to see your
thoughts because you look like you got a
couple things I disagree with you just
about all of that first of all McCarthy
announced the morning before the speech
yeah that that Medicaid and Associated
off the table I'm not going to consider
Cuts in any ways Joe just lost his big
Bugaboo issue they always use in October
a vote against the Republicans they're
going to cut your Social Security it's
very clear that that's not in our plan
I've also never seen that kind of
reaction at all in a in a uh in the
State of the Union Address they take one
Senator Rick Scott who has a plan by the
way I don't think any other Senator
supports uh and uh he signals him out
and tries to imply that that this is a a
a
this is a more emblematic of the overall
Republican party so uh I don't think I I
think he just lost an issue that they
use as a scare tactic because no one
understands and Trump by the way tweeted
about this prior to the event that to
the Republicans saying Social Security
and Medicare have to be off the table uh
the other thing here of course is that
our politics moved so fast and our
electorate is so volatile that any
conclusion we reach here today or any
impression that Biden makes uh on the
voters
can change within days I mean as we've
seen in this recent controversy
regarding the Chinese surveillance
balloon an event like that can so
completely suck up suck up the oxygen on
all political coverage and change things
overnight
no I absolutely kind of agree that he
did I was surprised by Biden be quite
honest I mean every time he goes up to
speak you just wonder what he's going to
do to screw it up or how he's going to
make it look worse but in this beach
overall I was I was thoroughly impressed
he looked presidential and especially
considering the way he was at his
campaigns speeches and how he's was
stumbling and going back and forth and
you're like what what's going on it was
like watching a NASCAR race and
everybody watches it to watch I want to
see the big crash and you just saw some
fender benders but nothing really really
bad happened because mind you when I
watch speeches like that module I'm
embarrassed as as an American citizen as
a veteran because I'm I'm biting my
nails like what because he messed up a
couple times some words you know he's he
can't really articulate them I think he
said prescription drugs once but he was
like
he's like like a four-year-old but I
mean it's just like you're waiting for
like mistake and like who knows but he's
he's right on the edge of like even the
way he walks I mean I feel I genuinely
feel bad bad for him because I think
he's he's at that point I don't I don't
think he should run but I by the way the
running conversation is a different
conversation yeah that's a whole
different conversation we can have
afterwards but to me you know right
afterwards Sarah Huckabee Sanders gave a
speech and she said you know I'm
officially the youngest governor in
America at 40 years old and President
Biden is the oldest president ever at 80
years old to give the message that she
he gave so I think America is kind of
tired with you know the messaging all
I'm saying is in this specific moment I
want to find that scene because I think
it is a scene that we have to see I
think I found it here where he gets
everyone to have to stand up it's at an
out yeah there it is it's right here
I'll send the link to you to go to hour
in one minute uh to share with them but
I'll keep going with the other topics
that I have
um he had the parents of Tyree Nichols
there which is a good way to connect
with what took place and uh a very great
opportunity for uh connection to talk
about law enforcement needs training
great fine so he hit that if Congress
suggests a national ban I will veto it
great fine story of fentanyl which that
was a very bad look for him because you
don't talk about what you're fixing when
your leader who needs to go to the
Border Kamala doesn't even go to talk to
the people at the border it's a hundred
percent hypocrisy whether you're middle
Center left right it doesn't matter you
can't talk in that topic with a lot of
um
credibility I thought the baby that
fought cancer I thought I was a good
story great story that he gave heartfelt
again he hit the heartfelt messages uh
that took place Paul Pelosi standing up
I don't know who said to have even a
shout out to Paul Pelosi I don't think
that was a good look because things are
too fresh and uh you know you don't want
a guy that's hanging out with another
guy with a hammer and a beer in his hand
in their underwear to kind of give an
endorsement to a person like that's a
little awkward that's always another six
or twelve months before it was it was
weird but to make that I think that was
like like feel bad for don't get me
wrong I felt bad the guy was attacked
but all this stuff leading up to him and
the police video all the questions of
what they said it was so what you saw
was like wait a minute they looked like
they were just somebody walked in on
them you know what I mean so but the but
the the one where he tripped on his own
deal is the one that I just gave you if
you can go to that the one that you had
up originally which was the oil issue
okay which was the oil issue which I
think is this one yeah one yeah
for a decade
I'm not going to exceed the play the
player I'll be honest look at this watch
this this is what the with the oil yeah
you need the audio you don't need oil
for that oh yeah this was it you're
gonna shut down all the oil wells and
all the uh oil refiners anyways
I said we're going to need oil for at
least another decade
you shouldn't have said that we're gonna
need it you see him when I talk to him
you say we're afraid you're going to
shut down what did you think about this
one so much for the new green deal
exactly absolutely I mean look it's a
reality you had you had for the first
time you had energy Independence under
Trump every president Republican and
Democrat they always pledged it nobody
ever did it uh there's enough natural
oil and natural gas under the under U.S
territory to fuel the country for the
next hundred years uh for the first time
we don't have to go hat in hand to the
Middle East or to Venezuela for oil
we turn on the Russian Pipeline that
Trump shut down we shut down our
pipeline this makes this makes no sense
at all and now Joe Biden has just
essentially uh contradicted the dogma of
his party that we need to be moving off
fossil fuels immediately I thought it
was one of the weakest parts of the
speech and of course Republicans were
high-fiving each other yeah by the way
that was uh again you
so here's kind of how I see this
there are a few people who can do
without the teleprompter he's not one of
them definitely at all okay if you were
to even count on your hand how many
people can give a talk for an hour or
two or three without a teleprompter
it's not a long list of names okay who
would you say you you you followed this
sport closer than anybody else Trump is
one of them who else can go without a
teleprompter very few we make an
excellent point very few would you put
Obama on Dallas and Clinton on that list
uh I think Obama could probably do it I
think so I think he's taste talented
Clinton Clinton could definitely do it
the problem is Clinton would talk for
two hours yeah
they're like like giving the light to
get off he was good though when he was
tired at least he wouldn't entertain you
when he would do his part all I'm saying
is to follow him here's kind of how this
works it it's like you know you're in
your floaties in the middle of the ocean
you're okay you're doing fine okay you
let the floaties go oh [__] it's risky
yeah I bet a lot of the people who are
the speech writers they kept saying
president of mine suggestion just stick
to the teleprompter yep you can pause
take your time but just read it slowly
we're gonna be okay the moment he was
out there without the floaties yeah
they're probably like oh my God what are
we going to go so I won't he made one of
them up which is the Medicare and Social
Security because he got that older vote
the baby boomer vote the way he did it
well maybe he got them to listen but
then he slipped out with the oil one
yeah and the old one where the Democrats
are like bro you just stick to the flip
and script teleprompter what are you
doing so that's the part with him so I
he had his flip flop he had a few
turnovers but I also thought he made a
few good plays no absolutely I think
especially with the on the on the
Democrat side of how they've been so
against the oil the green New Deal and
pushing that forward the reality is
there's no doubt that there's going to
be some sort of transition to some point
down the road but obviously they're
pushing for a very heavy now everything
abolish oil get rid of it this that and
the other and what he just proved was
that the reality is that's not the case
but that's what they're pushing for so
he just kind of screwed up their
argument on that end the other obvious
uh balloon in the room not not the
Chinese one is it he has a little
section there he talks about being tough
on China and saying well we just were
tough on them but in fact we let this
balloon into U.S airspace we let it
essentially navigate all the way across
the country from Montana to the
Carolinas
and then only then and only then do we
do anything about it other than sending
a strong letter to the Chinese I think
he sustained more damage from that over
the last week than anything he picked up
with tough on China rhetoric in this
speech the Chinese were paying us
billions and billions and billions of
dollars in tariffs he canceled that
program the Chinese clearly watching are
fumbling in Afghanistan watching what's
going on in in Ukraine they've
definitely got plans regarding Taiwan
and the lesson of history is that
weakness provokes aggression weakness
provokes War
yeah but the Spin Doctors showed up very
quickly and they set a balloon under
Trump was there for a while and you know
nothing was done about it and these
balloons are normal balloons and then
the the average voter who's sitting
there saying oh but maybe this is just a
normal thing with all these balloons
that they have I I don't think I don't
think that so the Secretary of Defense
says nobody told me that there were
Chinese balloons in U.S airspace nobody
else in the National Security apparatus
so I think it's an effort to try to make
it usual no big deal yeah I I don't
think I don't think it works you don't
think it worked you know how I typically
know when it didn't work is the
following way specially with his biggest
opponent right now who is president
Trump right so if president Trump talks
about it he senses it as a weakness of
the opposition his opponent and he knows
who his opponent is can you play the
two-minute clip of what president Trump
said he called it the real State of the
Union Beach I love it so here's a former
president Donald Trump
Rob we can't hear him without audiobooks
millions and millions
over the past two years undebiden
millions and millions of illegal aliens
from 160 different countries have
stormed across our Southern border drug
cartels are now raking in billions of
dollars
from smuggling poison to kill our people
and to kill our children
Savage Killers rapists and violent
criminals are being released from jail
to continue their crime wave and unto
Biden the murder rate has reached the
highest
in the history of our country
Biden and the radical Democrats have
wasted trillions of dollars and caused
the worst inflation in half a century
real wages are down 21 months in a row
gas prices absurd and are now going up
much higher than even before and the
typical American family is paying two
thousand two hundred dollars in
increased energy and food costs each
year Joe Biden's weaponized justice
department and I'm a victim of it is
persecuting his political opponents his
administration is Waging War and Free
Speech they're trying to indoctrinate
and mutilate our children he's leading
us to the brink of World War III and on
top of all of that he's the most corrupt
president in American history and it's
not even close but the good news is we
are going to reverse every single crisis
Calamity and disaster that Joe Biden has
created I am running for president to
end the destruction of our country and
to complete the unfinished business of
making America great again we will make
our country better than ever before and
we will always put America first thank
you okay so so millions of immigrants
yeah 160 different countries he's gonna
that's his campaign he just gave you his
pleasure right there yeah signature
issue beautiful yeah exactly absolutely
Savages and rapists are being released
from prison Sanctuary cities or you know
border find grade three real wages are
down 21 months in a row economy to
strength typical American Family paying
2 200 and increase energy and food costs
it's felt Middle America he's talking to
low and middle income families the
average family is spending Joe Biden's
weaponized justice department
perfect on what is going on with that
and now it's backfiring on Biden he's
going to play that no problem he's uh
turning us into potentially world war
three leading us into World War Three
that is a very very uh it could be a
valid issue that he's bringing up he's
the most corrupt president ever we don't
know what's going to happen now with
Kevin McCarthy and them leading the
house the investigation that you're
going to see every day hunter or
somebody's out there being talked about
all this stuff they're gonna have to
address that and then he came back and
said I'm going to come back we're going
to make put America first again so uh
you know if you only watch the State of
the Union you're Blown Away by you know
you're like okay this was a decent
speech if you watch it from Trump's side
you see all the flaws if you watch it
from Sarah Huckabee's side you see the
flaws if you watch it from CNN side they
were ecstatic on how great of a job he
did so it all depends on who's watching
it right so so but here's the point up
that when we're seeing
this taking place with the uh the State
of the Union given being given and Trump
given what message he just gave
at what point
do you sit there and say okay because
Trump hasn't yet turned on the throttle
on really going campaigning this isn't
Trump campaigning yet
with the timing of when the state of the
union is first week of February okay and
on Election time we got what right now
22 months 21 months whatever the
timeline is
when do you see historically where all
of a sudden this Full Throttle Trump's
going 100 offensive when does that
happen first of all I think his uh
announcement of candidacy was more of a
marker than it was the beginning of a
campaign he was letting everybody in his
own party and in the other party know
I'm definitely running you don't need to
speculate about it secondarily
um while he is raising money uh and
between the time he announced uh and the
end of the filing period he raised 9.5
million dollars now to me that's a lot
of money people say oh he underperformed
well he's no overhead because he's not
out doing rallies the rallies by the way
are a half million dollars a piece a
half million dollars so uh you know he
is he's he has a very lean staff uh he
is doing events like he did in New
Hampshire in South Carolina which keeps
his ex his campaigns expenses down
because you don't recognize those now
need to be paid for by his by his
re-election campaign uh and uh here's
where I think he is making an error and
hopefully he will change his mind uh
he's been putting out some very good
issue oriented videos I thought that was
a very good video uh but he needs to put
them on Twitter
uh it is a mistake to just continue to
to post uh solely uh at true social
first of all I love to social but it is
by definition uh you're talking to your
base 100 it is a great place to talk to
people not all of whom but most of whom
agree with you but in terms of talking
to everybody
your supporters uh and your opponents
and those in the middle
um I don't think Twitter can be beat uh
he has 87 million followers on Twitter
he has a little over three million uh
followers I think on true social I could
be a little off on that uh let's say
that a substantial number of the people
following me on Twitter are Bots
well let's say it's 50 which I don't
think it is yeah well that means he has
42 million people I mean that's still an
enormous number of Pizza so I'm hopeful
that he will begin posting this this uh
content this video content particularly
he doesn't have to use Twitter you know
for his for his sniping yeah which he
loves to do of course uh which is just
kind of part of his political persona
but I do think he needs to occasionally
occasionally go back on Twitter is there
is there any is he contractually binded
to troop social or he's not okay he's
not so do you guys think this is like a
tactical move where he's just waiting
he's biting his time to actually like
just hit it Like Pat was saying to go
full throttle and then it all comes out
or he's or he's just like does he still
have like a sour taste in his mouth from
the way he was treated and and and
banned uh the most predictable thing
about Donald Trump is that he's
completely unpredictable so it's hard
it's not I love it and it's not always
easy to understand exactly why he he's
doing what he's doing but in all cases
he's doing it with some purpose I do
think he understands that the very first
time he goes back to Twitter that's a
huge story that's an enormous story and
therefore when he goes there he should
go there to say something of substance
uh these videos are are really quite
good but they're not getting the kind of
residence I think they they could get if
he posted occasionally on Twitter can we
can we do uh uh uh what do you call it
can we put a poll and ask how many
people today on this live are actually
on Truth social I'd be curious to know
how many people are on truth so if you
have to guess what would you say Pat
from the people in the chat less than
five percent are on truth I was I was
gonna say less than five and I think
that's a high number okay to to be on
true social I don't think that many
people are on Truth social so but here's
the question though
um you only get to do your first tweet
once right first you'll come back to it
you only get to do it once and I believe
it's gonna end up being the most liked
tweet in the history of Twitter and the
most retweeted tweet on the in the
history of Twitter until it's like a
terrible waste of a first opportunity if
it's like a video if it's something
that's really solid it'll be
record-breaking you know 100 200 300
million views is what the video is going
to get I believe that
do you think knowing him he's hanging
tight to make sure that the first one is
not only perfectly timed to maximize the
effort to not just waste it right now
because it's too early to drop Twitter
well put it this way I agree with your
analysis that the first time he does it
will be a mega story that's like times
five rallies right right in terms of
reach uh and he does have a good sense
of timing so yeah I think he I think
he's going to use it both when he has
something very important to say and also
when there is more Focus right now in
our party he's the only candidate
running the field is not has not been
has not been filled uh there's a lot of
people
did she formally announce her did she
announced that she's going to announce
I'm not sure but she made her intention
right you know so I think it'd be fair
to to counter as a candidate I guess
um but I do think it is a it's an asset
that he will use at the right time to go
back to another point you made and I
think this is an absolute kid which is
two billion dollars more for Ukraine in
this speech
two billion I mean it is it is true that
particularly because of U.S based
coverage of the war most Americans
support Ukraine uh most Americans are
opposed to Putin uh and Russia but at
some point we have 370 000 homeless
veterans in this country uh and uh in
the end I think it'll be up to the FED
as to whether we have a recession or not
it is entirely possible Republicans more
than all voters recognize the
correlation between massive spending and
inflation uh and inflation is uh the
number one
along with immigration I think the
number one and number two problem for
this Administration so uh I believe the
war not only am I worried about us kind
of stumbling into World War Three
um but I also think that it's very
conceivable that like the Vietnam War
like the Korean War the war could become
very unpopular over time the longer the
war goes uh the more unpopular will
become because of the cost uh and also
the software our economy is the more the
resentment that we are seeming to be
just running the printing presses and
sending this money uh to Ukraine
so um I do think Trump's greatest single
potential opportunity
uh is to run as the peace candidate and
as Eisenhower said I will end the war in
Korea Nixon said I will end the war in
Vietnam given the Middle Eastern peace
deal which Trump got done which no one
thought possible given the fact that it
was Trump who turned off the Russian
Pipeline uh and Trump who gave the
offensive weapons to the ukrainians that
Obama would not give them uh given
Trump's diplomatic success success in
North Korea where he at least got the
Mad ban to to stop his nuclear weapons
development testing which is now
restarted under Joe Biden I mean I think
he has credibility as a deal maker as a
negotiator and I think he appealed to
that anti-interventionist
streak in America and particularly the
Republican party in 2016 and I think uh
I think he will do so again
what are you going to say yeah so I
think just to pick you up of what Roger
was saying in terms of Ukraine I
definitely think that U.S has passed the
line that Putin kind of Drew in the sand
to begin with of supporting Ukraine and
specifically through military equipment
through the taxes that they've been
sending and stuff like that so if Putin
really wanted to I think that he has
Justified a reason on his end uh to
really launch full out further war on
that end but my concern would definitely
be more on the uh on the opposite side
of China versus uh Russia really
starting something that we'd kind of
accidentally stumble into Roger at the
end of the day because I'm as a veteran
too just like Pat too when we're giving
all this money and we're helping we're
you know the the ACT to me is everybody
where the flag and you're great we're
sending all these billions what is the
end what are we in it for that's an
excellent question because we signed a
treaty in 1994 between Ronald Reagan and
leader uh Gorbachev in which we agreed
not to push Ukraine into NATO which
means really not to mount offensive
Western Finance missiles on the ground
in Russia
we do have bioweapons Labs there the
administration stumbled and admitted it
then they tried to pull it back uh and
if you say well we're there to support
democracy
zielinski has arrested everybody ran
against him in the last election he's
outlawed all the other parties he closes
down newspapers he closed down TV
stations he closes down radio stations
he arrests journalists he just closed
down the largest church in the country
so this is it's not about democracy uh
and I think we have been provocative now
people watch that say oh there you go
Roger Stone is a Putin apologist he
loves Putin he's a russophile no I I had
family members mowed down by Russian
tanks in Budapest in 1956. I have no use
for Putin he's a thug I have no use for
their for their system uh but I do this
is most certainly not about democracy uh
and uh I really fear that we could
stumble into World War III I agree and
it doesn't help when we have in my
garage I was telling Pat earlier I used
to I was stationed at Malmstrom Air
Force Base in Montana in regards to the
Chinese the the balloon situation we
knew it was traversing from China as of
last month on the 28th Let it Fly all
the way to Great Falls Montana over
Malmstrom Air Force Base which is a
nuclear missile base that I was
stationed at no no care in the world
apparently they're monitoring and it
wasn't looking and just the fact that we
let it come into our airspace I I
there's no excuse for anything like that
unless just saying that China we like we
we still haven't held them accountable
for covet so you know whatever now
there's a supply plane and it doesn't
seem like anybody really they don't even
care the biggest thing I saw was that
they canceled the trip to China and that
was their response of okay we're gonna
we're gonna push back on you we're not
gonna show up on your trip I don't think
the Chinese care too much about that
not at all really I don't think they
care so let me just read the balloon
story and let's kind of hear some of the
stuff on there so Chinese spy balloon
over central USA will be in U.S airspace
for a few days Pentagon says this is a
February third story so it's an older
story so defense department spokesperson
General Pat Ryder said Friday that the
Chinese surveillance balloon hovering
over the U.S has moved into a central
part of the country but the client again
to specifics no problem the balloon is
currently flying about 60 000 feet above
sea level higher than civilian aircraft
the Biden Administration has condemned
the presence of a China surveillance
aircraft in the U.S airspace as a
violation of U.S sovereignty but nothing
happens okay same day Trump says shoot
down the balloon okay president Trump on
Friday called for the U.S to shoot down
the suspect of China's high altitude
survey surveillance balloon that had
been spotted flying over different
states and the reason they shoot down
the balloon Trump posted on his truth
social Office of Naval intelligence
veteran human events senior editor Jack
basobic agreed with former president
assessment writing you shoot down the
balloon and launch bombers from Guam
that's gonna that's what you do when
Homeland is threatened Stephen Miller
trumps former senior advisor for policy
and White House director of speech
writing blamed current President Joe
Biden's weakness for the decision to not
shoot down the balloon okay so then this
continues U.S military shoots down
Chinese spy balloon over Atlantic Ocean
do you guys want to shout it down while
the balloon was off the coast of South
Carolina the balloon was shot down by
U.S military fighter jet on Saturday
afternoon senior defense officials said
during the Thursday afternoon briefing
that the U.S government is confident the
surveillance balloon is from the people
Republic of China senior U.S officials
said that the government was considering
a plan to shoot the balloon down while
it's over the Atlantic where it wouldn't
harm any individuals on the ground
official added that the U.S government
could potentially recover uh the balloon
and then there's even uh comments about
the fact that China wasn't happy that we
shut it down see that story where why
would you shoot down the balloon yeah
they said that they might might even
take action against us because we shot
down their a spy balloon over our
country and we also can't seem to be
able to get a straight answer about
whether we in some way were able to jam
their transfer of information uh back to
China we don't we don't know the answer
to that exactly did they did they end up
picking up the balloon they said they
they were going to try to do that but
when it when they thought like like the
recovery after yeah I mean I'm pretty
sure they did but but I what I I failed
to grasp and understand is they well
they monitor everything it was it left
over an ocean if you wanted to knock it
down that's where you knock it down is
over that ocean not the Pacific before
it's not before it's starting so you're
basically giving people the green light
come come and spine I don't believe the
whole rhetoric of well we were
monitoring it they weren't really
looking at certain things that we didn't
want to it stopped over Great Falls
Montana right over a nuclear missile
base I'm not stupid I don't think that
people are stupid but the way that they
spin it it's trust us nothing we don't
want to blow up a balloon because we
don't know what's going to fall out of
it we're letting it come over but who
knows what could been on it who knows it
could have a bomb it could have anything
on it we have no idea China's pushing
the envelope because they know and you
mentioned that Roger from from the
Afghanistan withdrawal we have no idea
what we're doing uh uh Biden you kind of
invited uh Russia to attack Ukraine when
he said you know a minor uh incursion
wouldn't be you know we would tolerate
that he basically gave him a green light
and now something like this nobody
respects us when it comes to to defense
and they don't respect uh Joe Biden I
think it's showing when they're when
they pull off stunts like this it's a
test I think I think it's a test uh I
mean I don't think you can shoot down
the balloon uh in international you know
airspace but as soon as it was over U.S
Sovereign territory boom we had an
obligation to act uh and then just the
the more the days stretched out and the
whole country is like recording get on
their phone there's more there's more
balloon memes
yeah they took over the egg memes if you
were to give it because you said it's a
test if you were to give the Biden
Administration a grade on how they
respond bonded to that test what would
that create it would be an F okay
it would be F because they waited so
long I mean I you know I I think you
have to move immediately on those things
and if it turns out to be true that
there were balloons over U.S territory
during the Trump presidency and some in
the military didn't tell the president
or the sect def because they feared that
he would do exactly that wow that's a
real problem no I think I think also
especially if you're saying like it's a
test what if they're trying to see what
how much they can do was still getting
away from it so if they were to do
something finally then the boundaries
already drawn so far out that they'd get
further Head Start in a sense before we
react because now it's like oh they can
go over our airspace they can do all
this this other stuff without Russ
really giving a reaction so then you've
kind of drawn the lines there yeah I I
think I think the biggest thing is
there's two things okay one is you go to
a place and to measure someone's
toughness and to measure you're
someone's the other I did a poll would
you rather be respected feared admired
and then there was another one loved
right and for whatever reason respect
was number one 55 and I think feared was
number three or something like that to
see those three again respected feared
admired and loved right
uh which by the way in a life
uh you know like a regular person just
living a life they're probably wanting
to be respected right which makes sense
but if you're a world leader you want to
be feared where people don't do anything
you're at a bar
you're sitting with your girl you have a
reputation
your girl's beautiful
so if a guy totally fears you and
respects you doesn't even talk to your
girl to come and say anything to her
right
if a guy is trying to see maybe you're
okay with it he'll come and be friendly
with your girl
but if she comes and says to you hey do
you mind if I dance also with your girl
he doesn't think you care if he dances
so not to some people like that's not a
big deal somebody has to dance also with
your girl
what China is doing right now is saying
I don't think he's gonna mind just put
the balloon out there they're not going
to do anything they're going to take
their time and they're going to think
about it because they don't want to make
the wrong decision so you know the whole
thing that indecision is more worse than
actually making a decision so this was a
sign of indecision we were afraid of
making a decision and unseen like the
other side is going to come after us no
you got to call the shots can you play
the can you put the Yahoo article I just
sent you on top right second one so Pat
comes Kamala Harris would be China and I
mean Kamala Harris's husband kissing you
know what I mean yeah exactly that's
exactly what that would be exactly what
I'm saying so watch it it's a Yahoo
story so go to the top so we can see
it's a Yahoo story so this is a yahoo
story if you can just go up a little bit
yeah China is mad at the US for blasting
it's suspected spy balloon but a few
years ago State tv bragged its fighter
pilots could shoot one down okay so so
again China's met a 2020 Chinese State
tv clip showed off how fighter pilots
could shoot down surveillance balloons
the video shows a pilot tracking and
shooting a balloon during an apparent
training exercise China said on Monday
that the U.S shooting down a suspected
Chinese balloon was unacceptable China
is upset at the U.S shot down the
balloons TV got it the video on channel
is encountered in the video and alarm
Bell prompts a fighter pilot to prepare
and board a fighter jet and peers to be
the Chinese j-10 a multi-role got it a
CCT narrative reaction saying that
loading missiles powering up checking
the fuel uh uh uh what what is the word
right there the fuselage and other
procedures were all completed quickly so
if you can go a little lower to see who
said they were upset about the fact the
supervising command organized judged
High surveillance the CCTV the white
balloon Explorer and the launcher so
they're explaining what happened to it
so who who are these guys to say you're
upset
that we shot down your balloon yeah what
do you mean you're upset and who gives
you the audacity to even say something
like that they can you know we're upset
that you shut down the balloon what
makes you think we care yeah what makes
you think we care about your opinion
whether we shot it down or not who's a
priority you know I think it is our
relationship with you or protecting the
safety of our citizens are you out of
your mind when you make a comment like
this but the audacity
to even say something like that don't
care that's why because but but I don't
think
they can do that under strong leadership
I absolutely I don't think you can even
make a comment like that you know what
happened but you know what happened
within 24 hours oh really no problem 25
tariffs exactly yeah that's what's going
to happen say that one more time to us
because without us China when you were
not even a top 10 economy in the world
just 50 years ago when uh your former
friend came and struck to deal with
those guys back in whatever the 60s was
you wouldn't even exist
on what you did you needed the help of a
smaller econ smaller Nation more
powerful uh economy to help you realize
that capitalism Works to be able to
compete with everybody else now you want
to talk to these guys like this you you
you America helped these guys turn into
what they are today and now they're
flipping and saying hey you disrespected
us it's an insult a key point that I I
moved to make at the time Richard Nixon
uh uh recognized China they had more
oxen than they had cars they were a
backwards agrarian society and they were
broke Nixon has no way of looking 30
years in advance to see that the
clintons are going to sell the military
secrets and the bushes are going to give
the most favored nation trading status
we are the ones 30 years later uh who
build China into a dangerous superpower
at the time Nixon's trying to get a
strategic arms limitation agreement with
the Soviets the Soviets are starting to
go cold on on
she says okay I'll go over and see Mao
maybe he wants to make a deal and then
he got his agreement so I think he
skillfully played the Chinese off but to
say oh well all of our problems with
China that all goes back to Nixon
there's no way for Nixon to have seen
those events Roger let me ask you a
question how how do you view India
the the DNA the DNA I'm not talking
about like I'm talking the DNA of India
who is India to you
I I can't even answer the question I
don't have an impression I've never been
there I don't know I I guess what I'm
asking for like they just did they just
pass up China and total population I
think I just saw a report a couple weeks
ago either they're there or they're
about to pass up China because the
average age in India right now is 27 the
average age in China is 20 38.4 years
old so China is getting older and
India's getting younger because India
doesn't have a you know one child family
policy India is like keep making the
babies right and China is now realizing
we made a big mistake we kind of need
the younger generation to lead an
innovation so
India apple is now moving a lot of its
manufacturing chips all of that to India
gradually without offending China
because China could fully disrupt uh
Apple's business if they turn on Tim
Cook so Tim Cook's I believe Tim Cook is
doing it very subtly
and say no China we're still going to
make chips with you we're just moving 25
to India no no China we're going to make
ships with you we're just moving 50
percent if China all of a sudden thinks
that they know he's going to move 100
away from China I think China is going
to make a disruptive move but here's
where I'm going with this
the U.S companies are sitting there
saying where can we build the things
that we need to build Biden's speech he
talked about how in U.S we used to make
40 percent of the chips now we make 10
yep we saw a statistic a couple years
ago during covet that used car prices
doubled all of a sudden because China
was producing 80 percent of chips that
one Asia was producing 80 percent of
chips I think it was China Indonesia I
think it was like a few countries that
were doing 80 if you remember that
statistic right we've all seen that
so now the fear is if we go in bed with
India what is the history with Indian
and again I'm not asking because you
said I don't have a thought on it
I wonder what
so so for example a carrier insurance
carrier I used to do business with big
company you know who they are very big
company
they approached us we signed a contract
okay we go to their City they invite us
down I meet all the executives all the
c-suits it's a great experience we can
do a lot of business together
uh direct competitor of mine has a
meeting in their meeting they tell them
if you don't drop your contract with
them we won't do business with you those
guys were bigger than us okay
the following Monday a big player come
to what comes to us from that company
the one that we signed a contract with
they fly out with their lawyers
and they said we need to meet with you
with our lawyers the only time insurance
carriers come and meet with the CEO with
lawyers is because they're terminating
the contract so I say no problem let's
go to my office so we go into my office
I'm sitting there with my chief
compliance officer my and a couple other
guys and you see this guy
says we're here to terminate the
contract I said what's your cause
we just don't think this relationship's
going anywhere I'm like very weird you
have to have like placement isn't good
or this isn't good in this case we've
had it where our placement wasn't good
and we lost the contract in this one we
didn't have
so I said but I want to hear a reason
now I know the reason because I know the
CEO of the other company gave a speech
and that speech a guy that was in the
room came to our company and he called
me and he says hey just so you know in a
recording in a speech this is what this
person said to you about you
so you don't have a reason no we just
don't think this relationship's going
anywhere no problem
that guy who came and terminated the
contract is no longer with the company
the guy above him his boss just reached
out this week he wants to have a meeting
with me one-on-one we're gonna have a
conversation ticket and sit down and
talk
I decide whether I want to do business
with this guy or not
protect the relationship in the way we
write up the contract is to make sure
you can't suddenly within a week
terminate my contract you got to give me
a two-year uh what do you call it run
rate before you terminate right the only
concern I have is if America locks onto
another Nation to be our number one
provider for chips or technology or
resources
we have to be careful to not strengthen
India in such a way that years later
they become the next China 2.0 and it's
2035. now India's bullion American we're
saying [__] we created the next Monster
so if you go back and you think about
the deal that Nixon struck with China
and what U.S has done with China the
last five decades how different approach
would we take with a country like India
to make sure we don't turn them into a
another country that bullies us because
they know they own us well I think it
would require having a president who
says perhaps we shouldn't be making our
chips outside the United States perhaps
we shouldn't be making our most
important pharmaceutical drugs outside
the United States isn't the best way to
keep control of these industries and to
provide economic opportunities for
Americans to build these things here so
why are we Outsourcing them always
because the labor there is cheaper yes
but the National Security implications
are obvious uh add to that that
countries like China but specifically
China are systematically buying up all
the natural minerals like Cobalt things
that we need to build chips and to build
uh other technology I think that this is
where the policy of America First and
returning these uh National Security
sensitive Industries back to the United
States is absolutely key and so my short
answer is I wouldn't be making the chips
in China or India I'd be making a mirror
well here's here's a challenge though
with that who brought Toyota to America
who brought Toyota to America
remember when we're like wow you know
competition America is only who GM
against Chrysler against you know
obviously same thing versus Ford and
this this that I was like no we should
let Toyota in
so this is when if you remember Milton
Friedman's old videos when Toyota came
into America hey let's let him compete
what a Toyota Force Ford and other
companies to do and make cheaper cars
and improve because Toyota was producing
a good car for Middle America so we
helped Toyota blow up into what Toyota
became because of U.S sells Toyota guess
what other people sell it as well so we
allowed BMW we allowed Mercedes we
allowed all these other guys to compete
against the other car makers who won
realistically the the U.S citizens won
because we forced Ford and a lot of
other guys to compete to produce a
better car but we didn't stop making
Fords and Chevys in the United States
exactly they wouldn't stop making them
but here's kind of where I'm going with
that I agree today I have 10 engineers
in my office in Dallas but I also have
10 in India okay
you the engineers I pay here let's just
kind of throw a number out there if
they're 150 here they're 50 in India
so so what they'll do is these
technology consulting firms will come to
you and they'll say we can do the same
work for you
but you have to pay 150 with us you only
pay 100 Grand a year for these guys so
they take the split between the the
salary they pay them which is a 50 50.
they keep the 50 they have to deal with
the HR and they get the project done so
hey the next Sprint is going to require
293 hours for this upgrade it's going to
cost you this much the next spring
anyways we do the math with that
so as long years
um labor is going to be cheaper in India
in you know other places the capitalist
is going to find a way to save money by
using those resources because for for
Apple to build an iPhone chip in India
versus America
Roger the numbers the person is going to
say oh you want to buy an iPhone and
build an American no problems 2500 bucks
I don't want to pay that's crazy exactly
because the labor is expensive here but
the labor is cheap in India so it and
then the alternative is to say what well
you can't build it in it's got to be in
America
then the average American takes a hit I
can't afford to buy this so it's a very
much of a tight cyclical cycle that
we're all need this is why China knows
America needs China right now we can't
step away from them dramatically all I'm
saying is we're leaving China that
resignation from China is coming may
take five years may take 10 years may
take 15 years it's coming okay when it
does we have to deploy it elsewhere for
5 10 15 20 years one of those places is
going to be India how do we do that to
make sure when we give all this business
to India they don't all of a sudden
become the next enemy we're dealing with
10 20 years from now
that's the question so I think I think
kind of to go back off of what Roger
mentioned earlier that Nixon wasn't
necessarily the one that that caused
China to become China what it is I think
there's a lot of mistakes along the
along the way and I think the biggest
thing that we've learned here is that
China can take everything that we have
but we can't send what we have to China
so as long as India doesn't just close
off itself where it says okay we're
gonna now take your Facebook and we're
going to call it India Facebook we're
going to take you're this and we're
going to call it this then as long as
you have some where there's a big open
where not only is America itself a
market for consumption but also we
produce and we sell things to Europe and
all the other places where as where
China is a they produce for themselves
and then they produce for the rest of
the world so as long as you're able to
have it go both ways then I don't think
there's as much of worry of that as what
we face with China where even if if you
invest in China you can take the money
out if you do all the limitations are on
the way now and that's where I'm going
yes and that's where I'm going then I
think the structure on how we brokered
that deal needs to be in place before we
deploy all this business to them let's
let's let's put a deal together yes
here's what the deal has so there's
there's a really interesting thing
actually that they did in Norway was
when in nineteen in uh December 23rd
1969 I'm pretty sure when they found oil
in Norway uh what they did was that
American companies had gone into a lot
of other countries and basically just
done private bought the land brokered a
deal uh had the resources and then
funneled the money out more or less
right but in Norway what they did was
they set up a structure in terms of like
you're saying a deal of who's
responsible who gets what right so in
this case there was a lot of help and
assistance from America where obviously
conquer Phillips shell a lot of these
companies made a lot of money Exxon you
name it but at the same time they also
helped educate the Norwegian Engineers
so that so that over time they'd learn
how to do it and the deal deals and the
licenses were set up in a way where
Norway as a country also benefited
vastly from the resources as well as the
private companies that came in to
develop and help essentially get the oil
out of the ground so Pat what would you
put in a contract like that what you
know about stuff like this what type of
iron-clad stipulations would you put in
so something like a China doesn't come
up come about where it says not it's not
too aggressive on our side but you know
make sure that this doesn't happen
yeah I mean here's here's how I look at
these things I don't know it's the
number one answer because I need to see
the deals but in if if I'm selling my
company to his private Equity Firm okay
and they're coming in ore if I'm selling
20 to them 50 to them 55 to them or 100
to them right you're gonna have 20
different uh deals that you're
negotiating okay 20 different markers
you're negotiating
board seats he wants three out of five
hell no you get one out of five because
if he's got three out of five they can
fire me okay well I don't care about
three out of five because he's buying
sixty percent anyway so who are you to
say no he can't have three out of five
how about we make four out of seven I
get three you get four I still have
those three in there let's not make it
five let's send it to seven okay I don't
care I'm still fully in control all
right there's the price there's a dollar
there's my commitment afterwards there's
a non-compete how long do you want me to
not compete if I'm selling the company
to do I have a two year non-compete
five-year non-compete 10-year
non-compete there's 20 things that you
negotiate right first thing I would do
is I would go to the guys that have done
the deals with all these other countries
and say what are the 20 points let's put
them all out and I'm gonna tell me the
history of the deals where we won the
most
tell me the deals that we had where they
won the most and why so China won 90 to
the point of us winning they won a lot
and we gave them way too much control
covet exposed the hell out of how much
U.S relied on China to even make the
shots the vaccine all this it was just a
very ridiculous thing that covet Exposed
on how much I knew once you get those
things
then you sit there and say hey India
here's what we're willing to do if not
guess what you do well whether you do it
or not we're going to let Apple produce
the stuff here really no problem
anything Apple sells that's made in
India it's going to be a 25 tax on an
Apple go ahead so forget about putting
it on you we're going to put it on Apple
so they can't come to India or you can't
do that that's our number one customer
no [__] it's your number one customer
but they're out of America so let's have
discount okay okay America I understand
what you're saying of course you
understand what I'm saying let's do a
deal where long term you understand we
brought this business to you wait a
minute Pat who wrote your remarks was it
Donald Trump
I was gonna say I was gonna say Pat 2024
yeah no but by the way that's what was
attractive about him doing the deals
with the people that he did do you know
who speaks like that do you know who
speaks like that
who speaks like that operators
a person who runs a company a person who
operates a military a person who
operates a team a person who's in it
that's dirty ugly nasty not a politician
they don't speak like that because
politicians like
yeah I got you a deal I got you deal
don't worry about it I'll see you at the
country what he always used to say is
that uh the other countries send send
Killers to the negotiating table we send
social workers yeah you're right uh and
you see this goes all the way back to
1988 where he's saying wait a minute uh
I'm I'm for free trade but I'm also for
fair trade your markets have to be open
to our products as well as vice versa
and this is also why he opposed these
one size fits-all trade agreements uh in
favor of doing an individual deal with
Germany and a different individual deal
with France and an individual deal with
any nation which makes a lot more sense
rather than this one size fits all TPP
uh and so on so I think it's about
reciprocal rights I mean you would not
want to put yourself in a situation
visas we say India
where we're moving jobs and business
there but their markets are closed to
our goods and services uh Roger
uh I've been in the financial business
for 20 years there's insurance companies
will go to on their floors all the
engineers I'm not going to name them but
I've been to most of them
I say hey we got 300 Engineers here
really yeah what are you recruiting from
MIT nope IIT
IIT yeah what's IIT where's IIT based
out of India
IIT is officially a better school at
producing Engineers than MIT
I don't know if you've ever seen this
exercise they did it's pretty epic they
take a battery a wire and all these
basic things and they go to an MIT
Institute graduate and they say hey here
put this together they're like oh I
don't know how to do this then they go
and do the same thing at an IIT
Institute graduate oh this is easy we'll
learn this in our first year and they
put it together and then they said as
good as MIT is IIT is passing these guys
up I spoke at their University in Mumbai
I don't know what year it was 5 000
people were in the audience and you can
see the hunger in these guys's eyes and
they're all about technology you know
Innovation all of that so I think these
guys are going to be the next China
they're a little bit more reasonable
they're a little bit easier to deal with
they also have a history of issues and
problems their enemy is Pakistan and a
few other guys neighboring people that
they have uh I uh
anytime a company you would much rather
negotiate with a company when it's worth
a billion dollars than when it's worth
100 billion dollars I think U.S has to
start negotiating now before
it's too late and they say no we don't
want to negotiate with you that's all
I'm saying uh this whole podcast just so
you know Roger if you didn't know it was
really an India podcast
this was not a state of the union
podcast yeah I'm Glad You Came very
prepared okay let's go to the next topic
go to uh uh Vinnie's favorite singer
performer Sam Smith if he can show that
so good the Tweet with the recent
Grammys I know you guys are all watching
it very closely so Sam Smith Tweets this
out okay this is going to be special
Grammys okay and he posts the picture
and by the way if you saw his
performance it was just like uh uh
little Nas X and it's it's something
that it's very provocative you get a lot
of eyeballs and all this other stuff
CBS response and says you can say that
again we are ready to worship
this is not CBS Sports no this is not
CBS underscore Larry Jackson's account
no okay that's got a CBS and it's a bot
this is the CBS account with a yellow
badge next to it not even blue because
when your media they give you that
little yeah check mark right there how
do you how do you look at this Kai when
you see something like this you're so
the reason why I'm asking you is the
following how old are you Kai I'm 24.
okay 24 years old the person that
probably tweeted this it's probably my
it's probably your age right insane
which is insane sure yeah now it's wild
now to have something like that going
out how number one how bad of a look is
that on CBS horrible okay so so horrible
in what way like is this thing gonna be
like it's gonna go away you know sweep
under the rug I think just like Roger
said earlier in terms of the new Cycles
are so quick here that yes this is one
of the things it's going to be it's
gonna be really bad for another 24 hours
and then the World's Gonna Move On
nobody's gonna care that's really where
things are at at this point that's
that's how well so the people that do
mess up that make these big mistakes and
you know from getting arrested to doing
things like this there's so much
information and their attention span is
so short that like mind you the guy did
a satanic music video live on this thing
worshiping that he was the devil and
then CBS is saying yeah we're here to
worship they're obviously not talking
about Christianity which whatever your
religious belief says but there's a they
don't care they're out in the open but
like you said this story after today
nobody's gonna talk about it no until
you have some other Hollywood spectacle
in which they uh essentially raise
Satanism which which will happen of
course um it's the most important thing
to come out of the Grammys I was
completely and totally justified in
including Harry Styles in my 14th annual
International worst dressed list did you
see what discovered I don't even know
yeah
you didn't like your style you don't
like how he dresses well here's the
thing four or five years ago he was on
the best dress I mean he dressed like a
pruner who's wearing got a cool
button-down suits and which one that one
right there this one looks like a clown
suit
you don't like that one would you would
you I can't see you in that bag it would
be very weird if I wore something like
that you know Roger here's my here's my
question to all of you you guys like is
this just like that just like that
performance type situation the same
thing with CBS are they doing it for the
eyeballs Pat and just because think
about it not only we're talking about it
I was at the supermarket somebody else
was like did you see his uh people were
talking about it and now you're looking
at him there's eyeballs more followers
more people or is it just oh sure
because you know like you're you're
watching a satanic performance and then
the people like wearing outfits like
that it's like what is it just for the
attention by the way can you please go
back 30 seconds and uh uh Eric if you're
in the back actually play this put the
screenplay just let it play and it's the
performance he's got you know they're
doing what they're doing
okay
and then watch at the end
okay and they're gonna go to commercial
they're going to cut the commercial
ready
CBS
[Applause]
watch watch
[Laughter]
I didn't even notice that timing by the
way we can't make this stuff
and then yesterday he did talk about we
can't let big Pharma pay the amount of
money okay for diabetes many of you in
here are taking the medication they
can't increase it more than 35 dollars
I'm like listen you're calling that big
Pharma but you know I don't know what
percentage of CNN's money comes from Big
Pharma I don't know what percentage of
these big media companies money comes
from Big Pharma what do you mean you're
calling those guys out so bash them
while you're giving a speech but behind
closers take their money of course and
that and how how awesome is this Pfizer
and we're talking about attention spans
the James O'Keefe the project Veritas
thing came out where one of the
directors of research or whatever is
like oh yeah we're we are in-house
mutating uh covid just to make people
have to buy and pay for new vaccines and
then look and then Pfizer just shows up
and people forgot about that story
what's crazy is Pfizer pulled all of
their advertising from Twitter when Elon
Musk bought it back in November so they
felt that Twitter anyway Elon Musk was a
danger to society but then we can have
Satan worship on the Grammys oh yeah
exactly but I guess Maury told me is
that who who was watching that
performance
found that entertaining I just don't I
mean it's just it's not entertaining it
isn't it really isn't who was who was it
I apologize for my uh generation on
behalf of all of us
you know who was the what's the guy that
they called him Mensch he wrote a book
and we were gonna super Mensch he wrote
a book called Superman she lives in uh
Hawaii today what's Shep Gordon you know
who shot he's a documentary yeah by the
way amazing fascinating guy Chef Gordon
is do you know about his story what he
did so he he signed a lot of different
people Shep is uh uh uh Kai you would
enjoy studying this he was around during
Jimi Hendrix and all these guys he was
all their managers and stuff he goes and
stays at a hotel he's moving to L.A
because he wants to get into the
Hollywood business at the hotel he's
staying at Jimi Hendrix is staying there
a bunch of guys are saying that are not
a big name yet and they say well I need
representation he chooses to represent
them and he's working with one of the
heavy metal guys that he finds and who
is it man let me find the dark the it
looks like a crow yeah what is their
name Alice Cooper Alice Cooper so he he
gets he represents Alice Cooper's Alice
here's what you got to do he says cut
the neck off this chicken and let the
blood uh pour onto your face and I'm
telling you gonna blow up what the hell
are you talking about he says can you
just trust me here's the chicken
and let the blood pour out he says are
you serious he says you hired me just
trust me so anyways obviously he listens
put the pictures of Alice Cooper and the
chicken can you do Alice Cooper chicken
and then blood type in uh blood as well
right next to if Tom was here we told
the story much better than I would just
put blood that Gothic crazy look right
there yeah so they they take write their
chicken to the left you see that so he
cuts the chicken's head off the blood is
right there he breaks the neck and blood
all over the place what happens is
everybody talks about it yeah and
everybody wanted to go to his next
concert and he becomes a sellout okay
all the concerts sell out so there is a
part of it where it's like you know it's
a shock Factor thing that you do but
it's just getting really old because you
know I I can't think of the last time I
watched the Grammys I don't know if
people tune into it like the way they
did before
anyway so there's Shep Gordon for you
let's go to the next story next story is
about uh uh the the recession so will it
happen will it not happen but there is a
bank that is talking about here we go
the CEO of America's second largest bank
is preparing for a possible U.S debt
default this is a CNN story Congress is
once again bickering about raising the
debt ceiling the amount of money the US
government can borrow to pay its bills
on time and that means that Corporate
America has to be ready for the worse
the CEO Bank of America America's second
largest bank City hopes lawmakers
resolve their issues uh because the
market and economy love stability yet
defaulting on the countries debt remains
a possibility that cannot be ignored we
have to be prepared for that not only in
the country but in other countries
around the world Bank of America CEO
Brian uh Moynihan said you hope it
doesn't happen but hope it's not as
strategy so you prepare for it U.S
treasury secretary Janet Yellen has
already warned Congress that the country
could default on its Financial
Obligations as soon as June if the debt
ceiling is not raised before then what
are the chances that the debt ceiling is
not going to be raised zero zero zero
yeah they do this every every time every
time it's the same conversation yeah
it's a kabuki dance there's no there's
no question about it but uh I still
think in the end though it is a chairman
Powell who's going to decide whether we
have a recession or not well chairman
Powell is going to decide yeah the FED
is going to decide and and what do you
think is going to happen that you right
now Goldman Sachs just lowered the odds
of a recession from what it was before
to now 20 25 is 45 yeah from 35 to 25
this is an Insider story according to
Goldman Sachs the odds of U.S economy
slipping into recession has dropped from
35 to 25 over next to the upgrade and
forecast is due to the combination of a
certain job numbers and Improvement in
business sentiment a better than
expected 517 000 payrolls were added in
January which suggest hiring is
continuing despite Rising inflation uh
but other economists are more
pessimistic surveys by Bloomberg and
Wall Street Journal have found the
consensus view that there's a 65 chance
of a sharp and severe downturn in
downturn in the upcoming year what do
you think is going to happen first of
all I think these things are all
manipulated of course because I'm a
conspiracy theorist so uh I I don't know
if you could tell from the tone of
Biden's uh State of the Union speech
that he is hoping for a soft Landing a a
recession would really be problematic if
in fact he gets to run for re-election
uh I don't know what's going to happen I
think the different I think the odds of
the recession are somewhere in between
in other words I'm not sure there's 65
percent but I'm also not sure they're 25
I think they're somewhere in the middle
25 you don't think is 25 you don't think
it's 65. so if you're a betting man
would you bet on it happening this year
where the announcement will be made U.S
goes into recession well first of all
they never announced it in fact they
even when you're in the recession they
deny that you're in a recession so it's
not like they make a formal announcement
but I do think you could have a a
substantial slowdown in the economy yes
more than what we've seen I definitely
agree on terms of that and obviously
unless they edit the definition for
recession well they did what the White
House did when it was two quarters of
negative growth they're like no no no we
didn't say that they changed the
Wikipedia definition they're like no no
we didn't that's look it up it's a new
thing like give you an example
vaccination to me that that used to mean
that well you take this and you're back
you're protected from being infected you
can't be infected so this can't be a
vaccination then can it because what do
I need a booster for I mean if I already
had the vaccination yeah three before
boosters Roger you can't say you don't
trust science
don't do that on the spot yeah yeah you
know doctor we respect Dr Patrick
because he is you tried to play it was
such a great conversation the other day
where this girl asks me a question she's
trying to get me we talk about the sun
yeah Alex she said why don't you try
psychedelics and she says you trust
science don't you and I said define
science and she couldn't even answer it
I said because the definition of science
has changed a lot the last three years
what is science to me science is debate
if we can't no longer have a debate then
there is no such thing as science
anymore scientists can't sit there and
debate their issues on each side so
here's very weird data I wonder if
you're surprised or you're not surprised
like does any of this surprise you here
single women own
2.64 million more homes than single men
in the U.S let me finish this article so
let me say that one more time
single woman on
2.64 million
more homes
than single men in the U.S okay on an
average woman earns around 83 cents for
every dollar they earn okay compared to
a man in the U.S single woman on a total
of 10.76 million homes whereas single
men own 8.12 million there's a
difference of 2.64 and the Gap is
growing and 48 out of 50 states single
women were found to own more homes the
two exceptions were North and South
Dakota
which only three people lived there and
then Louisiana Alabama and South
Carolina had the greatest share of
single women homeowners Louisiana
Alabama and South Carolina on average
across the three states single women
owned 15 percent of all owner occupied
houses
where a single men owned 11 percent
although men earn more than women on
average that is not always true for
younger generation according to new Pew
research
uh Center younger women
women younger than 30
earn more than men and cities including
New York DC and LA
let me read that last sentence to you
again according to peer research center
women younger than 30 earn more than men
in New York Washington DC and LA
what do you think about this these stats
so the first stats like surprised me a
little bit but then I kind of clicked
for me where um remember the video we
did on a single moms versus dads that
had kids yeah so the far majority go
with the mom right and at that point who
needs a house if you have kids to
provide for versus no kids so if you
kind of correlate or if you add the
single mothers with kids that are taking
care of them into custody versus a
single dad that's taking care of it in
custody then the crossover there I can
see how those numbers make sense but
then but then okay so if your argument's
gonna be divorced I just pulled up the
top states 10 states with the highest
rates of divorces New Mexico is number
one West Virginia so what if you never
got married
kids out of wedlock or kids you never
get married where a couple splits up but
they've never had a legal marriage then
you're not divorced you're just we're
just parting ways uh so his house goes
to her no he he never had a house she
has need for a house yes because she has
the kids yeah but she's taking care of a
kid and and uh I'm not saying yes then
probably he's less money to be able to
buy a house but you'd also need a house
in that situation more so than I
understand you need a house there's a
difference between needing a house and
affording a house absolutely affording
yes
but who's like again that was what I was
looking at it but the more interesting
thing is what about the pay inequality
what about that whole argument yeah I
mean in three major cities this is new
uh under 30 women are being paid more
that's that's sexist is that also can
you pull up that article by the way just
zoom in a little bit is that maybe
because uh women under 30 more of them
are going to school and getting a higher
education and especially if you're in
one of those three states they're very
for equality in terms of pay and equal
opportunity then you have younger people
who are higher educated by the way I
want to continue to read this article
I'm actually curious right now okay so
we talk about North Dakota and South
Dakota okay great in Florida Maryland
and Delaware the difference in home
ownership between single men and women
was the greatest across the three single
women on average owned around 4.5
percent more homes than men we're
talking Florida Maryland and Delaware
there is no correlation between those
three states it's interesting women are
paid less than men on average and earn
83.1 percent of what men earn according
to U.S Department of Labor the figure
compares the median wage of all
full-time male and female workers in a
country using data from 2020 and as the
most comprehensive analysis of the
gender wage Gap to date according to the
data from National Association realtors
in 2020 to 19 percent of buyers for
single women whereas just nine percent
were single men in 2015 single women
made up 16 percent of the buyers were
single men made only nine percent in the
gap between Sigma that is very weird to
look at this so
um I think if you if you think about who
prepares more for a rainy day that
mindset I I'm gonna give that Victory to
women yeah who thinks more long term by
saying let me at least buy a house and
you know make some kind of an investment
this is a
and if they're single pet and they're
dating then they're not paying for
drinks popcorn at the movies they're not
paying for dinners of course they got
money to buy out house they're not out
spending I mean because those girls it's
they're single it's not that they're not
dating you feel me Rob
no robbers Rob's in love yeah you're
married
that's nuts this is a everybody here
spooked a little bit yes is that for
sure yeah are you still spooked Roger or
is this making you think a little bit
because I'm I'm not making a lot of
sense at it me too because I'm trying to
figure out why why those three specific
cities is very interesting Florida
Delaware America well but also New York
L.A L.A Washington DC
the government's the biggest employer
right that makes sense but I can't
figure out why the other two but by the
way this is a uh this is a story to okay
men typically purchase homes that were
249 000 last year compared to women who
purchased homes that were 230 that's not
a big difference yeah it's not even 10
it's five percent difference and
sacrifices women are generally more uh
more likely to make included cutting out
non-essential spending taking second
jobs it's kind of like what you're
talking about canceling vacation plans
yeah okay there you go very interesting
article I'd love to see more stats and
data uh on uh on this here I'm canceling
my date this weekend Pat she's paying
for it um she's paying for it because
I'm looking at the houses you're a
homeowner I don't have a house I live in
an apartment yeah you're paying for this
thing here okay BT let's talk about what
happened with Israel Israel's president
became the first world leader to
publicly use Chad gbt when he gave a
speech partly written by the AI okay
which by the way what a great story for
this year uh what page is that on there
it is okay so Isaac Herzog the president
of Israel became the first world leader
to publicly use the technology Herzog
recorded a video message
for the special opening remarks by at
Cyber Tech Global Tel Aviv 2023 cyber
security conference it's not the
underground plumbing one this is a
different one in front of an audience of
20 000 the president then revealed that
the opening section was written by GP
wow at least being honest before
concluding that AI is not going to
replace humans the AI written section
began I am truly proud to be the
president of a country that is home to
such a vibrant and Innovative high-tech
industry the President also used Chad
gbt to end the speech with an
inspirational quote let us not forget
that our humanity is what makes us truly
special it's not the machines that will
shape our destiny but rather our hearts
minds and determination
and the Machine and a machine wrote that
and then
that is so how do you feel about that
how do you feel about that I mean for
for me I think that AI is definitely
something that we've seen coming and it
doesn't surprise me like obviously I'm
sure the setting of this with it being a
a Tech Convention and stuff like that is
very fitting where it's kind of like a
cool gimmick on that end uh but in terms
of if there's a speechwriter doing
something that's drawing up the initial
draft or it's uh an AI or robot I mean
at the end of the day it's going to be
edited the human's gonna look at it and
they're going to revise it and change it
and then go from there
maybe not
yeah I just think it's Wikipedia on
steroids
somebody sent this to me last night
where they asked uh they asked chat what
about Roger Stone we don't comment on
conspiracy theories wow really so I'm
already banned oh that's hilar I mean
right right out of the box I mean I've
written you know I've written Five Books
five Amazon bestsellers two New York
Times bestsellers but my My Views are
too far out there for AI and look it's
really and look at the flip pad I mean
I'm a stand-up I'm a comedian I'm not
crazy well known somebody in the office
was like write me a joke in the voice of
Vincent oshana and it wrote a joke as me
and it was pretty close I swear to God I
don't know I forgot who it was but I was
like oh my God it's actually scary I
mean it's exciting and scary at the same
time but it's like this is this is just
recent imagine what's what's going to be
in like 10 years and the biggest danger
and thing that's kind of worrisome
obviously what Roger Stone was inclining
to there as well is that the input is
we're setting the limitations of what is
considered conspiracy and we're putting
they're putting that in the machine yeah
the machine isn't necessarily pulling
from it it's just saying what you can or
can't talk about the other thing was
when they were asking about Trump versus
uh Biden on the on the chat gbt and how
it was saying that uh in terms of the
questions they were referring to against
uh Biden was or Trump was no we can't
say that but then with Biden it was
something different so the inputs that
are being put into the machine where now
people are thinking that this is fact or
this is the way it is obviously excuse
the position and that's going to be a
big challenge going forward in terms of
what can we let slide and what can we
not whoever's operating if they're
biased just like you know the Department
of Justice we're [__] basically sorry
for my language or or just like
Wikipedia look you go to my media page
there's so many so so many mistakes and
there's some things are just factually
wrong sure I could hire somebody go
ahead and change them you know what
happens they just go back and change
them of course so if you want to know
about me don't bother looking at my
Wikipedia page because almost all of
it's incorrect is that right yeah I mean
you have to trust the internet because
if you Google my high type Patrick but
David height which is wild yes
no no wait let's put Abraham Lincoln
yeah I did I did quote Abraham Lincoln
go to uh look at this Rob was just doing
his homework right there if you guys
caught that height hi to go how tall is
Patrick with David
you know how tall is Patrick with David
which is people always say Pat
go lower one of them says how tall five
seven you're five seven wow by the way
not only that I'm 154. oh wow that's
okay if you look up my net worth says
I'm worth 24 million oh really
just don't mind Rob when you
die
Robert what would you say mine is what
would you say mind you I have 30 yeah
I'm actually I'm curious to see what
Vincent Lashana net worth would be watch
his Pat
three to five million dollars yeah is
that really what it says okay I
definitely don't have why are you
keeping all this money yeah because I'm
trying to catch up to the girls they're
paying for lunch I got you okay so let's
let's talk about this next door I think
you may have some things to see on this
one uh uh uh page 12. okay Trump reacts
to Haley the Santas and other
presidential 2024 Rivals this is an
Epoch time story former president Donald
Trump commented on the possibility of
former South Carolina Governor Nikki
Haley and other Republicans Challenge
and afforded GOP 2024 nominations in an
interview with radio host T Hewitt
uh he stated that Haley called them and
asked about it and he told her to follow
her heart Haley has previously
stated that she would never run if Trump
runs however he says she is ambitious
and he told her she could run if she
wants the South Carolina Senator Tim
Scott is also said to be considering a
bit when asked if he would support the
Republican candidate in 2024 even if
it's not him Trump said it would depend
he also claimed that Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis owed his election to him he
also stated that Jared Kushner the
husband of his daughter Ivanka won't be
involved in his efforts to secure his
presidency
um so what part of what part of it do
you want me to respond to well I'll ask
the specific question I think it's the
only one that uh today we're having a
conversation with at school and we're
talking to our friend Rob that I was
telling you about this morning on the
podcast
so if it comes down to these guys going
up you know politics you've been around
you know the the fun side the clean side
the ugly side there isn't any sides of
it you don't know about over the last
how many decades you've been a part of
it
Trump against the scientists okay
Trump has already poked a couple times
the sentences came up and said look I'm
gonna let my record do the talking for
me uh he won by thirty four thousand I
won by one and a half million we're
winning Miami day and all this other
stuff trying to say that a lot of people
are talking about me every morning I
wake up how do you view this yourself
from Trump against DeSantis Trump is
okay with Nikki Haley running because
she may make a good vice president
candidate one day possibly but there
seems to be a little bit of a discomfort
with DeSantis how do you process that
well first of all what Trump said is
true uh Rhonda Sanchez does always owe
his rise in American politics to Donald
Trump 67 of 67 Republican County
chairman in this state endorsed Adam
Putnam for governor the agriculture
commissioner every single Republican in
the state legislature including the
Senate President and the house Speaker
indoor stat and Putnam every member of
the Congressional Delegation with the
exception of Matt Gates uh and Putnam
was far ahead in both money and the
polls it is only the tweeted endorsement
of Donald Trump that turbo charges the
candidacy of Ron DeSantis so I think the
president feels uh The Descent is now
challenging him particularly after Trump
had to come here uh in the 2018 election
and essentially dragged DeSantis over
the Finish Line won by 30 000 votes
um he does see it as a personal Act of
treachery as an act of disloyalty and
he's unhappy about it and Donald Trump's
never shy about telling you how he feels
about things
um the other point people Mr Sanchez did
win but Donald Trump got 1.2 million
more voters in Florida in 2020 than
DeSantis gotten the most recent election
so I do think there's going to be a
contest but I think the reason that
Trump seems to be propping Nikki Haley
up is Trump is probably sitting at a
base in the party which is very intense
of somewhere around 45 48 percent of the
vote there's another 20 percent that he
could get but his hard base is somewhere
between 40 and 50. and in a
multi-candidate field he's in much
stronger shape in a one-on-one race you
know the sentence in all honesty is
untested as a presidential candidate uh
how big of a difference is that so so
for example for somebody to be a a a a
very very good candidate as a governor
who during covet he did very well and
you remember when the feedback that I
think Obama got from Emmanuel where he
says look you're not going to get a lot
of chances to be as on fire as you are
today you gotta run even though
everybody was telling Obama not to run
after the DNC speech all the he was on
fire he says you're not going to get
this again you got to run I am sure the
similar type of Rahm emanuels of the
right who are more DeSantis are saying
you're not going to be hotter than you
are today the between now and four years
from now a lot could change you have to
run how do you address that that he is
the most hottest Governor yet the
difference between being a governor and
a president what's the big difference I
I see why he's is doing what he's doing
I'm not I'm not defending it because I
think he could afford to wait but I also
must tell you that he's untested at this
level I mean he does very well in
Florida but that's where you control the
microphone he doesn't do well in a in a
wide-ranging uh uh uncontrolled
atmosphere particularly when it comes to
interviews uh you very rarely see him
smile he doesn't he does not seem to
like people he seems to me to be an
introvert in an extroverted business
potentially and how he's going to wear
as a candidate mixing with the pig
farmers in Iowa uh or the guys who grow
maple syrup you know in in New Hampshire
that that remains to be seen I also
think that it's kind of early I mean I
think he said it's high water mark right
now it's very early to Peak this
election as you pointed out early 22
months ago a 20 months always from now
and also people are going to be going to
want to go back and look at the record
so he said for example he would ban the
teaching of CRT in schools in Florida
well right here in Broward County they
have just adopted a curriculum from the
ADL which includes the teaching of CRT
and there's 13 other counties so he's
got a lot of pledges that were very
popular in Maga world that he made at
the end of the last election and he's
going to be held to those uh and I I
think it's so therefore it's not
necessarily clear sailing he is going to
run we talked about it here last time I
was here as a matter of fact he is going
to run but you're getting in the cage
match you know with a very tough guy and
I still think the end of the day Trump
would would defeat him to see what Megan
Kelly said
did you hear what Megan Kelly said Megan
Kelly said there is no way the
scientists can beat Trump he says
Trump's only going to need 30 percent
and his Maga crowd alone that 30 is a
lock
she said it's not even a good
opportunity for DeSantis to run I'm
paraphrasing what she said about this
and I said but okay let's just say you
do run the santis and let's say you do
be Trump actually go there that you do
be Trump
what is Trump going to do is Trump going
to say okay maggot crowd go and vote for
DeSantis that's the point she made and
then the second thing she said which is
a very very valid point as well as the
final one
what what is the likelihood
of trump say he loses let's say ten
percent chance 20 chance whatever the
number everybody is saying he loses to
the centers okay and now DeSantis is the
Republican nominee what is the
likelihood that the center is Trump in a
situation like that says oh really
that's what you guys want to do no
problem I'm going to run as a third
party yeah oh I think that I think he
would do it what's the likelihood of him
doing very very unlikely unlikely unlike
okay because of the uh because of the
enormous legal barriers
to getting on the ballot in 50 states
legal and financial barriers remember
we're not talking about a third party
candidate you're not the party of the
Liberty you're not the candidate of the
libertarian party or the green party so
it's an extremely expensive legally
extraordinarily complicated uh and
difficult thing to just get on the
ballot and if you have participated in
the Republican nominating process and
let's just say hypothetically you're not
successful well the deadline surpassed
for you to also compete as an
independent because they pretty much by
and large have the same deadlines
remember this
ballot access all election laws
are written by Republicans and Democrats
working together against any kind of
competition both extra party and intra
party so uh Trump could Bluff I guess
and he's done it in the past but uh why
would he leave the Republican Party he
is uh he has transformed the party into
the party of Working Class People
um I think she I think Megyn Kelly
understates the level of his support but
what she doesn't understate is the
intensity of his support Trump
supporters are not voting for anyone
else but the other thing about Trump
though as a candidate is he has makes a
lot of people go out and vote against
him just like he has the devotion of the
people that are part of his crowd he's
also very good at basically having
people vote against him he's very
polarizing yes just like say or I don't
know uh Joe Biden yeah big time okay so
let's let's do this and uh you had final
thoughts before we wrap up I just have
one body before finish up okay yeah I'll
read it I was just gonna say one thing
pen I'm sorry I was going to say though
but if like you said for some reason
whatever percentage he does lose that is
going to hurt the Republican Party
greatly because that whole mag of voting
crowd will not vote for santis like I
want to know your point and then so that
gives the Democrats such an advantage at
that point especially if he has that
hardcore Die Hard fans they're not going
to just go okay we'll just take the
Santas and Trump has a proven ability to
get votes in Michigan Wisconsin
Pennsylvania
who didn't vote for John McCain didn't
vote for Mitt Romney these are these are
not Country Club Republicans and I think
Trump's uh appeal to those people is
unique uh I expect Trump to be the
Republican nominee I still think he's in
very strong position were he not to be
the nominee whoever was a nominee would
urgently need his support but I just
don't I don't expect that's going to
happen I think Trump is well positioned
to be and last thing who do you think
because I'm from what we're looking
Biden's going to run who do you think is
going to go against Biden if you have to
pick right if you I know it's early I
should don't know that Biden finishes
out his term I mean how do we don't know
how the hunter Biden investigations
there's no light way to keep this
toothpaste in the tube anymore so we're
going to get a full uh we're gonna get a
full exposure to all of that
um uh most of my friends who are
professional Democrats and I do have a
few they really doubt uh Biden's ability
to win another election they also have
the same doubts about Kamala Harris and
I've said said it here I think I still
believe at the end of the day we're
Biden to either resign for reasons of
health or reasons of political health or
be removed by his own people under the
25th Amendment because he appears to be
too dysfunctional to do the job and
Kamala Harris would to become president
the only way you could remove a woman of
color would be with another woman of
color which is why I still believe that
Michelle Obama is potentially the
Democrats strongest possible candidate
wow
wow you still believe them yeah yes he
does yes I do so even though she's the
strongest you think she'd willing to go
with it or do it well I think it remains
to be seen the more she says she's not
that's a good reason to believe that she
is of course yeah she said she's not
well I mean Barack Obama is without any
question the most influential figure in
the modern democratic parties very
popular and he's very influential and we
know that Joe Biden was his last choice
I mean they tried to inflate the
tendency of Cory Booker they tried to
inflate the candidacy of Kamala Harris
they tried to inflate the candidacy of
people
it didn't work uh and I think they
recognize that both their president and
their Vice President are weak potential
candidates uh but look it's all
conjecture right now Joe Biden says he's
running for reelection last question
crazy question here so you know how we
had a celebrity run for office Ronald
Reagan hey you will not believe Back to
the Future you know the actor Ronald
Reagan yeah he's going to be the
president United States what are you
talking about right so nobody becomes a
uh uh now he was a governor of two terms
he was a president of a you know but at
the same time he became a president you
know Trump became a president do you see
anybody that's a celebrity type name to
become a president like a rock or any of
those guys
as we have now learned one of the
greatest single qualifications is to be
well known so until Trump all of your
Presidents had either been a governor a
U.S senator or a general for some you've
had a business person but not just any
business person a business person who
who seriously fed and burnished their
Public Image uh you know for for for 40
years so yeah somebody could emerge from
uh from the World of Sports or from
entertainment but I do think Reagan's
different Reagan was a successful
two-year two-term Governor the largest
state in the country so he didn't just
jump from from Death Valley days to the
White House I think that I think people
are looking for that now the difference
is in a business person whether it's
Ross Perot whether it's Donald Trump if
you build a billion dollar company then
people think you're qualified to run the
federal government
yeah somebody just did a Super Chat
saying uh Republicans are so soft they
let the November 2020 uh contest slide
and did absolutely nothing about it was
the point of Second Amendment uh if
you're too scared to execute don't
celebrate Fourth of July Constitution
was written for this
etc etc this is Ivan whoever it is I
can't say the last uh part of the name
anyways I mean listen it's a it I think
it's a very unpredictable time we have
no idea what's going to happen but I
think for in in regards to politics
eyeball sports like if it was a sport I
think this is a phenomenal season can't
wait the next 22 months I think is going
to be phenomenal I think it's going to
be like a uh what we saw with the World
Cup and how much you know intensity
there was in it's going to be similar to
that anyways let me comment on something
that happened this week so on Monday
uh we we had uh who was it we had Roland
Martin in the house we did a podcast
phenomenon I had a really good time with
them debate all of it was great but
certain things happened yesterday a
Jason Whitlock reacted to a video that
he made talking about uh uh what we do
at Value team and calling me names a lot
of different things
and he said the fact that he was invited
on Monday it was a set up to him because
we were trying to get him et cetera Etc
let me kind of read you a story to tell
you the story what happened here with
Jason Whitlock so the first time Rob we
invited Jason Whitlock was when
uh I believe the first time August of
2022. and you have the email of this if
you can zoom in so we can show the first
email that went in
and we blanked out his email address we
just did it yeah so this is the first
email that goes and it says hey we would
like to have you on to discuss your
story Etc et cetera Patrick's admiration
for Jason Whitlock I've liked this
content for a long time I think he does
a good job whether it's Sports he's got
a show called Fearless with Jason
Whitlock so perfect you send him a
message uh nothing happens you send him
another message I think December of 14th
you send him another email to have him
on the podcast correct that's when we
confirmed that he was interested in
coming in yeah and then from there we
decided we would figure out a good date
and this is the email that he showed in
the video yesterday saying the fact that
they didn't tell me anything I want to
show you these emails so everybody knows
because he showed the emails himself as
well uh thanks for getting back to me
the interview with cover Jason's career
at ESPN The Blaze his show Fearless
great this is emails he showed yesterday
which to date on this is December 14th
right then after this we schedule a time
for him to be on the podcast on February
16th correct then you get back to him
because February 16th I'm either
speaking in Vegas or Orlando next week
have travel so we asked to see if we can
do it on another date
simultaneously when we're going back and
forth to Tyree Nichols uh tragic event
takes place so I say I'd love to have
somebody come in to have a show and
preferably let's have a panel to be a
debate from both sides of the house
somebody that says hey even though the
five cops were black you know it's still
a systemic racism somebody that says no
it's not so we can have good banter
there you reach out to a list of names
one of them being Roland Martin Roland
Martin confirms with you when February
uh I believe sixth well yeah he said he
was going to be in town February 6th
which is this Monday this past Monday
right okay so you do that then you go
back to Jason Whitlock and you ask him
if he can do it on February 6th as well
well we've initially offered him a few
dates to see if he could come at a
different time because you were not
going to be here for the 16th he didn't
respond back so then I sent a follow-up
email and said hey we have limited dates
because the other dates were booked with
other guests could you do this date
which happened to be Monday February 6th
and from there he agreed and I sent the
next email if you want me to show so
before you show the other email this is
the criticism that he gave to us that I
want to you know kind of explain to the
audience what happened so both show up
here on the podcast
we have Roland who's running late uh a
few minutes so our driver that was
driving up Rob if you want to talk about
the driver that was driving uh Jason you
tell him hey since other guest is late
you don't have to worry about if you're
running late it's fine you're going to
be okay bring him in here I can't hear
your audio
there was no how about now there was no
rush to be here at nine o'clock on the
dot because our other guest was running
late so we're not going to be able to
start at nine so take your time getting
here right so then he gets here so
Jason's downstairs Roland is upstairs I
walk up to talk to Jason to say hey
Jason uh excited to have you here Jason
says hey beautiful building I couldn't
you know you guys got a big operation
here I said thank you I said the panel
that we're gonna do the podcast with his
Roland Martin
how do you feel about Roland Martin his
entire the missiology is completely
changed I saw him being very
uncomfortable and I didn't like that now
to be fair the email that Jason didn't
show his audience when he criticized us
is the email he got Friday three days
before the day the podcast which I don't
think Jason read so let's show the email
on uh on Friday that you sent in and
zoom in a little bit on this email this
email was sent to both him and it was
sent to Roland Martin can you show the
date February 3rd okay here's the
interview etc etc Monday February 6 will
be at the address etc etc and then
topics look at the topic zoom in a
little bit panel discussion on police
reform the 2024 presidential election
the U.S economy and a mix of current
events and trending topics keyword there
is what panel discussion on police
reform yeah that's what this show is
about this was on Friday he could have
said who was the panel did he ever ask
you part of the panel not once did you
get a question from who's part of the
panel no I did not did Roland ask you a
question who's part of the panel he did
not as well so neither one of them ask
you who's part of the panel no problem
so here's the thing Dan bongino invites
me on the show to be on Fox no problem I
go on the show to be on Fox they say hey
Patrick uh we want Patrick to be on Fox
to debate Bitcoin
first thing I tell Karina and Sam I'm
like I'm not a Bitcoin guy he says well
Dan wants you to go out there and debate
you know I said who's a debate we don't
know yet perfect I go on it all of a
sudden I get an email the person you're
debating because we ask who is the
person I'm debating it's going to be
Peter Schiff we did the show it got very
good views a lot of good feedback it was
great TV everybody loved it there was
strong banter Dan bongino won because he
got eyeballs because our audience showed
up we won because we were able to get
Dan bongino's eyeballs of his audience
and they saw us so both it's a win-win
this is kind of what you call Media but
uh Jason goes on and he says they didn't
tell me what it was about they didn't
tell me it was going to be showed this
was all a setup so again up until this
point this is what's not been shown to
everybody in his audience I go to Jason
Jason says there's no way I'm going to
sit with this guy he says a couple
different words he says he's stalking me
on Twitter all the time etc etc so I
said okay no problem I don't want to
make this guy feel bad because I like
him a lot I like his content I think
Jason's very necessary I said Jason how
about we do this let's just do podcasts
you and I and then I'll do Roland's in
an hour but let's do podcasts you and I
he says no problem sits in there I come
in here I tell you guys to prepare to
adjust
the moment we're about to walk out Jason
walks out
when he walks out Mario follows him
everybody follows him what's going on
they want to make this thing good hey
Pat he's not talking to us I walk out I
don't have any problem having a
conversation I said Jason what's going
on he said hey Jason what what is going
on let's just do a podcast here together
do you realize how much the blaze pays
me I said how much does the police pay
you they pay me a lot of money and I
took a day from my schedule on Blaze to
be here I didn't like that because I
hate it when people waste my time I
don't like wasting his time I said
what's your daily rate I'll compensate
you if that's how you feel but there is
no motive here we said it's a panel how
do you not see that it's a panel you're
not happy to face off Roland Martin
anyways he's walking walking by the way
he crosses the street red line I have to
stop I said bro just relax pump the
brakes traffic is kind of crosses the
street I said can I offer anything to
you no can I send you driver no I don't
trust this I don't trust that he leaves
no problem he takes off Roland comes
down we do a podcast fiery podcast we do
a very good job uh uh Jason talks about
the fact that he needed me to go against
a guy like Roland Martin because he
needed somebody that can go and handle
somebody like Roland Martin first of all
neither Roland or Jason Whitlock are in
the top 100 most intimidating people
I've ever sat with in my life I've sat
with Samuel bulgervan I've sat with a
lot of intimidating people very big
names I just like both Roland Martin
because he likes to get dirty and fight
and I also like Jason Whitlock because
he's got a completely different
perspective I probably agree with Jason
more than I agree with Roland Martin on
many of the policies if you watch the
podcast it was pretty obvious before you
see it so then he used the race card and
he said well uh uh this is uh this is he
would never do this with Jordan Peterson
he's using a race card you know what
he's trying to do is a you know he's
doing this because I'm black this is the
part that's very confusing he's a guy
that paints himself as a Conservative
Republican who doesn't like when the
left uses their race to act as a victim
but that's exactly what you just did
Jason and my idea was because I got two
suggestions here to final the finish
this uh thought of what we learned from
this experience and as well as feedback
to you Jason to wrap this whole thing up
because I'm not going to comment on this
again
number one what we learned from this we
will never waste our resources without
telling you who's going to be part of
the panel so when Rob and I had a
meeting in others we said let's make
sure everybody knows before we buy the
tickets because it is a waste of our
money as well we also lost money so
number one we learned from our lessons
made a mistake next time anytime we
invite with a panel we're going to say
here's who it's going to be before we
spend the money on the flight but I got
a recommendation for you Jason Whitlock
your show is called Fearless if you
really want to have a show called
Fearless you either become fearless and
face off with anybody to have a debate
with or you change your show's name to
fearful but you can't say you're
fearless and come to a place and then
say we have feminine energy and the
person that has the feminine energies
the person that walked out and we're
right here waiting for you so you go
ahead and figure that part out the way
you want having said that I respect the
work you've done I think you're a super
necessary voice I had a very good time
with Roland Martin I think would have
had blast if it was the three of us but
it didn't work out so best of luck to
Jason this is what happened to the story
that I that he didn't cover with you
guys when he went on a three-hour
two-hour live talking about this while
I'm trying to put my kids down
everyone's calling me let me tell you
what you said I'm like dude I don't I'm
putting my kids now right now I'm
spending time with Brooklyn yesterday uh
and I'm having a very good conversation
with my oldest son because of what we're
working on with his grades Rob did I
miss anything else from what I covered
here the only thing I would say is that
in this email chain uh I asked and it's
not on this email here but in a
subsequent email I asked for plugs to
mention social media handles to mention
and Jason responded to that so he was
reading the email there's no way you
could skip this portion and then answer
the portion below and provide your
social media handles for products so he
did see that email because he responded
to it correct I did not know that okay
so and then we had subsequent emails
after that his flight was delayed but I
mean it was all in the same email so it
was there for him to see if he had asked
us we would have absolutely said hey
here's the other panelists that we're
working on lining up so fantastic
anyways the the podcast with Roland
Martin there were so many other YouTube
channels reacted to the media reacted to
it I think total views were five or ten
million views Tick Tock Facebook
Instagram YouTube Twitter uh uh those
were fiery conversation and I respect
Roland Martin for sitting here funny
story Roland retweeted and said if I
knew I was going to be sitting down with
Jason Whitlock I would have never sat
down with him I destroyed this man a
long time ago
Roland just jumped in there to take
advantage of the opportunity anyways
okay there you have it uh Roger thanks
for coming out thank you this was great
remember not to get in a fight with you
this was great I had a great time with
you uh again uh Kai it's good to have
you back apparently Ward on the street
was he was you were fired so somehow
you're back here it's great to see you I
haven't we had a good negotiation by the
way a lot of people are thinking Adam
left or he's fired
unfortunately it is partly true we will
tell you the full story on next week's
podcast have a great weekend we may do
one Friday we may do a podcast on Friday
possibly can't tell you yet I have a
travel uh schedule tomorrow I'm going to
I don't know where I'm going to tomorrow
I'm going to Orlando tomorrow come back
if I make it back we'll do podcasts on
Friday if we don't have a great weekend
everybody take care bye bye-bye